my take on classic chocolate brownies is
guaranteed to put a smile on anyone's
face and not just when they're fresh out
of the oven
blondies
stock up in these delicious blondies
they'll keep for up to a week and it's a
great way of getting ahead of your
expecting guests round
first off melt the butter for the
mixture
we've had hundreds and hundreds of
brownies the sort of white chocolate
version i.e blondies are amazing a
little bit more subtle keep a little
knob of butter
for the end just to grease your baking
tray turn the gas down
and gently melt that butter
caster sugar into the bowl
[Music]
just give that butter a little whisk
sort of makes the mixture a little bit
lighter slightly fluffy
off with the gas
a pinch of salt in the sugar then make
it a little wet in the middle and sort
of whisk
you can see
it's already gone nice and blonde
love it
give that
a really good mix
and the secret with the butter be
slightly warm sort of
it melts the sugar
nice and smooth
lovely
a teaspoon of
vanilla extract in
next lightly whisk in two whole eggs
just give them a little beat
this is such
a delicious recipe yet so simple
whisk in the eggs looking for that nice
sort of rich
textured
smooth paste
you can see why we call these
blondies beautiful
next teaspoon of baking powder baking
powder in then half a teaspoon of baking
soda
that aerates the mixture and gives it
that little tartness you'll see this
sort of
rise instantly the minute they hit the
oven
and then
your flour whisk with one hand
and just
slowly
add half the flour first
get that all mixed up make sure that
mixture is really nice and smooth
check it
occasionally
no lumps half flour in
and then the other half in you'll feel
it sort of almost
nice and firm
and that's why it's so important to add
the flour in stages it stops the mixture
going lumpy
it should be just dropping off the whisk
beautiful
change over from a whisk to a spoon
next i want some texture some nice sweet
chewiness to the blondies
dried cranberries
they bake beautifully
but it gives the blondie a really nice
sort of chewy sweetness
in the center next
a white chocolate
[Music]
i'm not going to grate it i'm going to
chop it up just slice it like little
bits of shrapnel
i want the chocolate like little
matchsticks dotted around
now chocolate in
lovely
fold that in i want a nice even
distribution of those wonderful dried
cranberries
don't over mix it i want to break up
that chocolate
nice even mix of cranberries and
chocolate you can see the chocolate
there'll be parts of the chocolate in
the oven that will actually melt
it'll be like little pools of white
melted chocolate in the center
now
a baking tray
small little knob of butter and the
grease baking tray and line it some
greaseproof paper and just
over extend it
shiny side out dull side hits the bottom
of the tray in
greaseproof
allows me to maximize on the white
chocolate inside the mix no greaseproof
paper the chocolate can melt and almost
stick to the tray so the paper is just a
really nice insurance policy secondly we
want that rise and that sort of
crispness now with the mix get your
spatula all the way around i don't want
to see anything left in that bowl
position the bowl over your tray
nice and carefully
loudly
don't leave that slice in the bowl
nobody's licking that one
and then just take the back of the
spatula go into the corners push and
come back into the middle
turn the tray around let it work to your
advantage
try and get it evenly positioned in the
tray
if it goes in even
it cooks evenly
make sure you smooth out the top of the
blondie with the back of the spatula
and then into the oven it's going to
rise
nice and crisp
all that soft gooeyness in the center
bake your blondies at 180 degrees for 35
to 40 minutes
that
smells incredible
it's got that crisp edge on the outside
and that sort of soft gooey center
leave that to cool down and it's going
to sort of firm up and wrinkle but it'll
stay nice and gooey in the center once
it's cooled down take it out and start
slicing
[Music]
your mouthwatching blonde is a fantastic
easy treat to have on hand for yourself
or to share
my next recipe is a time-honored british
classic but with addition of spices it's
given a new lease of life fragrant
spiced rice pudding
i love cooking with spices but you don't
have to just cook savory dishes using
aromatics and spices across desserts
takes your puddings to a completely
different level
[Music]
first off our spices this is a fresh
vanilla pod fragrant
and packed full of flavor use the back
of the knife and flatten it that removes
all those little seeds
off the skin of the vanilla pod take
your knife
slice down the middle
and then when you open that up the smell
is incredible
take the tip of the knife and you scrape
inside and look
all those seeds
dying to come out that is incredible
there are thousands of seeds still
ingrained to the pod so put them
in
to the casserole cardamom
powerful
spicy
take two little pods
place your knife on top
and lightly crack them cracking the
cardamom pods helps release all the
amazing flavour cloves
gives it that kind of
aniseed
flavour with a lot of depth
one
two three
cinnamon stick
snap and in
[Music]
just smelling that level of fragrance
you can imagine what the rice pudding's
gonna taste off turn on the heat lightly
toast those spices just a couple of
seconds now what's gonna happen is just
gonna sort of enhance those spices in a
way that it just draws out an even more
powerful fragrance coconut milk in
sugar
two tablespoons
milk
and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream
bring it slowly to the boil to allow the
flavours to infuse and this rice pudding
reminds me of my time in india where i
got really into that chai tea fragrance
because it was just so delicious
and so comforting
take a lime
in
the lime just cuts through the richness
of the coconut gives it that nice little
bit of acidity goes fantastically well
with the cinnamon and that fresh vanilla
nice have a taste
now let's come up to the boil give it a
nice little clean around the outside
and in with the rice
use 200 grams of pudding rice don't wash
it beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven
and just turn that down to a light
simmer and the pudding rice starts to
open up and it absorbs all that coconut
vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out three to
five minutes
boiling it rapidly the rice opens up and
it goes into mush we want to keep that
nice texture that sort of fragrant rice
pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury
i want to show you how
i take this simple delicious aromatic
rice pudding to a completely different
level here's what i do take
two egg yolks separate them
now give that a really nice
whisk
two nice tablespoons of mascarpone
cheese
whisk that into the egg yolks
just so it's nice and smooth
it's almost like finishing the rice
pudding in a delicious custard turn off
the gas add that
into the rice pudding what happens it
starts to enrich and really thicken this
rice pudding and takes it to a
completely different level
the rice is still not cooked it's
starting to go nice and soft you can
just see how it's opening up
but looks like rich aromatic lava
bubbling away
finally great more citrus zest the lime
on top
roasted
caramelized lime zest on top of rice
pudding
is phenomenal
then put it in the oven for 15 minutes
at 200 degrees to finish cooking the
rice and develop the intensely aromatic
flavours
look at that
an incredibly fragrant
rice pudding how beautiful does that
look
spicy are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
i'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
my next recipe is a proper british
classic that's super simple to cook and
cost next to nothing a delicious apple
crumble
crumbles are the perfect way to use
fruit when it's in season there's lots
of it about it's nice and cheap but most
importantly the fruit's at its absolute
best
first off i'm gonna make a really nice
light caramel pan on nice and low great
two apples
[Music]
and this helps to almost sort of pure
the apple so much quicker
there's a lot of flavor in the skin so
don't worry about peeling the fruit
whether it's pears plums peaches
flavors in the skin
nice to start the caramel a couple of
tablespoons of sugar the sugar helps to
get rid of the tartness in the apple
a touch
of cinnamon that starts to make it a
little spicy open up your vanilla just
scrape out all those seeds now this just
makes it light and fragrant all those
seeds
in
to the sugar when making caramel be
patient and always swirl the dish
instead of stirring it
when the sugar goes brown add the apple
that starts to sort of cool down the
caramel
but it gives it a really nice sort of
caramelised puree
apple's almost disintegrating
smells incredible
turn the gas down
slice up two apples
it's a crumble that's got no frills
straight forward no faffing around no
peening of the skin
i want them to sort of stand out from
the caramel apples in
now those nice thick chunks of apple
sort of almost bedding itself into the
puree
dried cranberries gives it that nice
sort of shock in the texture
sweet and chewy
i want it to sort of taste zesty spicy
so
sit the lemon zest on top of your apples
and cranberry
fresh lemon juice over and that just
gives that extra acidic kick takes the
cranberries the apples the caramel and
the cinnamon to another level turn the
gas off
just let that sit
let's concentrate on the crumble
flour in
a couple of tablespoons of demerara
sugar sugar helps to get the topping
nice and crispy
butter in
give that a nice little rub what we're
looking for is like a
a bread crumb mixture lightly season it
with a touch of cinnamon
and the demerara sugar sort of helps to
get a nice fine crumble mix and it stops
the butter from sort of melting
in that flour
so that's the basic crumble mix
but i'm not finished yet muesli
two-thirds crumble
one-third muesli mix that in if you
haven't got muesli then crunchy granola
works brilliantly too
lovely
now start off in the center
and work your way around
i want the crispiness on the top
the puree on the bottom of the caramel
and then the texture
in the center a good tip
turn the gas back on i want it bubbling
before it goes in the oven because then
you just gotta cook the top so as soon
as you see
that caramel starting to bubble down the
side in she goes
let's go
bake at 200 degrees celsius for 12 to 14
minutes until golden brown
smells amazing
[Music]
beautiful
still bubbling
[Music]
and look at it
a delicious but very simple crumble with
apples at the absolute best
beautiful
[Music]
you